DUMOULIN BACKPASTERNAK SCORES!
BERGERON THE KEEP
IN, HAUL THE FEED,
DO, AND THEN IT'S
ABOUT PUCK
RETRIEVAL WHEN YOU
DEBRUSK A LITTLE
TOO AGGRESSIVE WITH
THE STICK, TRYING
TO GET THE PUCK.
SCORE!
BY PASTERNAK!
AN
AND.
THE BRUINS DURING
THE PUCK OVER, BUT
A MISFIRE AND LINE
RILEY BELOW MIDDLE.
BROCK McGINN, THE X
HURRICANE,  GETS IT
OUT.
CARLO TO COYLE, TO
DEBRUSK.
CARLO WIDE OFF THE
FORBORT AND THE
PUCK DRIBBLES
THROUGH
EXPERIENCING IT
THROUGH THEIR EYES,
AS THIS COULD BE
PATRICE BERGERON'S
LAST ALL-STAR NOD.
I'M NOT SURE WHERE
ITITAYMAN'S GLOVE.
PASTERNAK PICKS IT
UP, FLOATED OFF THE
BOARDS . HERE IS
BROCK McGINN
CENTERING PASS AND
HEINEN TUCKS ITHIGH
HE'S TRYING TO DEAL
WITH SOME CROSBY.
CARLO FROM HIS PUMP
A CHANCE AT AN OPEN
NET.
HERE COMES  TAYLOR
HALL.
TRIES TO OPEN TO
IT,  BUT WHAT A
STICK CHECK BY
BRIAN DUMOULIN.
ABLE TO
TO RILEY.
ERIK HAULA GAINS
THE TO McGINN
OFF CARTER'S SKATE.
COYLE
NEWS.
>> Andy: THE BRUINS
TRYING TO SURVIVE
THE CROSBY LINE
SHIFT AND
SMITH . MISS STICK
HANDLES.
CROSBY GETS THE
CHANCE FOR NUMBER
500 ON THE TWO IT A.
POSTGAME FINAL.
WHAT AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR THOMAS NOSEK,
RIGHT WHERE YOU
BRYAN RUST HAS BRUI
JUST COULDN'T
MANAGE THE PUCK, 10
FEET INSIDE THE
OFFENSIVE LINE,
PASTERNAK, SMITH
TIPS IT!
HALL JAMS